let's say that we're given the equation
that y squared minus x squared is equal
to 4
and our goal is to find the second
derivative of y with respect to x and we
want to find an expression for it in
terms of x's and y's so pause this video
and see if you can work through this
all right now let's do it together now
some of you might have wanted to solve
for y and then use some traditional
techniques but here we have a y squared
and so it might involve a plus or minus
square root and so some of y'all might
have realized hey we can do a little bit
of implicit differentiation which is
really just an application of the chain
rule so let's do that let's first find
the the first derivative of y with
respect to x and to do that i'll just
take the derivative with respect to x of
both sides of this equation
and then what do we get
well the derivative with respect to x of
y squared we're going to use the chain
rule here first we can take the
derivative of y squared with respect to
y which is going to be equal to 2y and
then that times the derivative of y with
respect to x once again this comes
straight out of the chain rule and then
from that we will subtract
what's the derivative of x squared with
respect to x well that's just going to
be 2x
and then last but not least
what is the derivative
of a constant with respect to x well it
doesn't change so it's just going to be
equal to
0.
all right now we can solve for our first
derivative of y with respect to x let's
do that we can add 2x to both sides and
we would get 2y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x
is equal to
2 x and now i can divide both sides by
2y
and i am going to get
that the derivative of y with respect to
x is equal to
x
over
y
now the next step is let's take the
derivative of both sides of this with
respect to x and then we can hopefully
find our second derivative of y with
respect to x and to help us there
actually let me rewrite this and i'm i
always forget the quotient rule although
it might be a useful thing for you to
remember but i could rewrite this as a
product which will help me at least so
i'm going to rewrite this as the
derivative of y with respect to x is
equal to
x
times y to the negative 1 power y
to the negative 1 power and now if we
want to find the second derivative we
apply the derivative operator
on both sides of this equation
derivative with respect to x and our
left hand side is exactly what we
eventually wanted to get
so the second derivative of y with
respect to x and what do we get here on
the right hand side
well we can apply the product rule so
first we can say the derivative
of x with respect to x well that is just
going to be 1 times the other thing so
times
y to the negative 1 power
and then we have plus
x times the derivative of y to the
negative 1.
so plus x what's the times what's the
derivative of y to the negative 1 power
well first we can find the derivative of
y to the negative 1 power with respect
to y we'll just leverage the power rule
there so that's going to be negative 1
times y to the negative 2 power
and then we would multiply that times
the derivative of y with respect to x
just an application of the chain rule
times d y
dx and remember we know what the
derivative of y with respect to x is we
already solved for that it is x over y
so this over here is going to be x
over y
and so now we just have to simplify this
expression this is going to be equal to
and i'll try to do it part by part that
part right over there is just going to
be a 1
over y and then all of this business
let's see if i can simplify that this
negative is going to go out front so
minus
and then i'm going to have x times x in
the numerator and then it's going to be
divided by
y squared and then divided by another y
so it's going to be minus
x squared
over
y to the third
over y to the third or another way to
think about it x squared times y to the
negative three and we are done we have
just figured out the second derivative
of y
with respect
to x in terms of x's and y's